in this video i'm gonna be breaking down
three ways cool ways to earn money
on youtube without adsense now adsense
is when ads play before your videos and
that's a great way to
uh kind of add even more income to your
bottom line but i'm going to talk about
how you could be generating an income
without adsense giving you some examples
and case studies and then as usual on
these coffee with candle episodes
bringing you on and answering your
questions but hey if we're just meeting
my name is sean cannell
my passion is helping you build your
influence
uh with online video uh wrote a book
with my friend benji travis called
youtube secrets and i'm on a mission to
help 10 000 people create a full-time
living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with online
video you know
right now we just learned that content
consumption's up eighty percent a recent
forbes article because of the lockdown
e-commerce order volumes up fifty
percent so there's really never been a
better time
to uh be leaning into youtube and
learning how to earn
money so if you're fired up for today's
training hit the like button
let me know where you're watching from
and this is kind of a special episode
because we recently did a youtube
challenge and i'm going to be bringing
on some of the people from
that challenge to join me for some q
a but let's start with the core training
and i want to share three quick ways
and kind of different ideas for earning
money
um from home with youtube now this is my
personal channel called sean cannell
um just first and last name sean cannell
rhymes with youtube channel
and on this channel i um have
i don't do a lot here you know we have a
full-time
uh video education company where we are
of course helping people with cameras
and lighting and gear
and a huge affiliate marketing business
with uh
amazon through a lot of tech but this is
a channel where i've done a lot of
different experience
experiments for example i actually
uploaded
this video with my friends um
jeff morse who we started a project back
in the day
and this was a time when i was vlogging
and i shot a vlog
and i cut out a clip of that vlog when
jeff's kids were watching beyblades
shout out if you know what beyblades
is and i had never heard about it so i
actually made this video
where um i just i did a full vlog i was
vlogging daily vlogging for
50 days straight or something and i cut
out an episode called beyblade and and
just uploaded it called it beyblade
battle and i um added music and like
sound effects and like these dramatic
tournament that we did with the kids
now look at this this video has 180
000 views can you believe it it's on its
way to a million
what i actually did was i took the
adsense from this video and i just sent
it to the kids and i
sent them a camera and some other stuff
because i was like i had no idea this
video was going to blow up
and and earn all this money um and so i
was like hey
buy but pay for your college you know
not that it was that much but it was
like
i don't know a couple like a thousand
bucks or two thousand and so um
and then notice though that i linked in
the description um
beyblades and so by putting out like a
beyblade
tournament um video and then
key like ranking it in search like it
gets views and still gets views almost
got a million views and people keep
watching it
in the description is links to
toys right beyblades now you got to be
careful with this um
and uh because you're really not
supposed to
or it's not you can't market to people
under 13 and that is a challenge with
uh people that are if you have a kid's
channel and whatnot but there's other
ways to monetize if you have a kids
channel in this case of course
it'd be like parents that would be
shopping and looking at these types of
uh things um and that also could
influence
uh you know amazon or or like the
youtube monetization but that's just one
example so i'm giving you like a couple
cool
ideas for how you can earn money this
was one i did
is amazon prime worth it so i'm actually
not talking about a product right i'm
talking about
amazon prime and i'm talking about the
features of amazon prime
now you actually get a bounty if people
sign up for amazon prime um
i don't know if you knew that and so by
reviewing
a subscription service essentially
or talking about it i've earned
thousands now of dollars by talking
about amazon prime talking about the
features
and then what people can do is click a
link in the description
and see
what's in prime prime shopping amazon
day
whatever else decide if they want to
sign up and if you think about this as
well
think about the strategy here like
people are wondering is amazon prime
worth it right and that's what they're
searching before they would potentially
want to invest in something like that
so i'm just dropping kind of like
different ideas that could lead directly
to
monetization here's another one um
gift ideas for men that one's probably
pretty pretty clear gift ideas for him
people are looking for gift ideas a lot
of different affiliate marketing and not
just amazon let's be clear that when you
look at something like this
if we look at the different programs
here typically it's mostly amazon but
let me see if there's like a different
one
h m skinny ties so
it's probably they're no longer around
since this video came out but that
i probably was a um a skinny tie
uh um affiliate link to h m if they had
one here's maybe a better one would be
mantree now i just did mantry.com i
think because i wasn't approved for an
affiliate program yet
but i think you could look at this you
can go to mantre which is a men's pantry
subscription service where the the stuff
comes to you in a box
and then you could sign up for the
mantra i need to sign up for this and
put a link in the description
because you get a 10 commission and a 30
day cookie duration what does that mean
that means that if somebody clicks the
link and
buys the box you get 10 of the sale but
if they click the link and they buy
anything in the next 30 days that's what
the cookie duration is if they purchase
it
on that device and so again this video
484 000 views and i've got the mantry
box
that somebody gave me as a gift so i
just turned it around and was like let
me review it let me talk about it in a
list of gift ideas for men let me know
if you're getting value hit the like
button
and let me know if you've started doing
affiliate marketing or if you have any
specific questions
now this one is a pretty crazy one
because it's best christmas laser lights
and i did this back in 2016 because i
was at my local grocery store here in
las vegas smith's and i saw
a shelf full of um
christmas laser lights you know the ones
that most people
you might think they're ugly let me know
if you think these lights are lazy and
ugly my wife was like i like the real
come on national lampoon's christmas i
want you out there with the staple gun
on the roof risking your life with the
ladder setting up lights
for six hours honey and i'm like look
these are my favorite lights babe they
might not look that great
but set up and tear down of these lights
for me
it takes 15 minutes and 12 of those
minutes was me trying to actually find
the extension cords
like these take i just go out like put
them in the yard so love them or hate
them
i spotted a trend there's a strategy for
you like spotting a trend of what are
people going to be searching what are
people looking for
what are people after and and i s when i
saw them hit my grocery store i was like
these are mainstream i wonder if there's
any videos on youtube and there wasn't
really and they weren't really well made
so that's kind of the essence of
i think really generating income you
know again is this what it's all about
no you make lots of videos on your
youtube channel they don't all have to
be product reviews they don't all have
to be
gift ideas videos they don't all have to
be directly correlated to monetization
this is just how you can fund the
mission how you can fund your passion
and a couple different ideas these are
really based around affiliate marketing
now i am doing a free training
um soon and so it's at idea to income
dot tips
and i'm actually going to be talking
about how you can take a youtube video
like this and actually monetize it in
four
different ways and i'm going to be
breaking down how
an exact case study with some nuances
and strategy of finding profitable
products profitable niches
things like that and how i turned took
uh a hundred and thirty dollars and turn
it into thirteen thousand dollars
if you're interested in watching that
definitely check out the free training
there's a link
if you're watching this on think
marketing um
to idea to income dot tips in the
description below um
if you're on facebook go over and check
it out idea to income.tips and if you're
watching this in the youtube influence
challenge group
then the link is already in the group
for you to just go to the watch page
if you want to check out that training
and we're going to go more in depth
about how to earn money but yeah i
promised you
about uh three cool ways of earning
uh money without adsense you know
i actually have rsi repetitive stress
injury and so
i'm a fan of cbd which is of course
non-psychotropic um uh
product of uh that is good for pain and
sleep and other things like that very
popular
legal in all 50 states of course really
really phenomenal so i did
uh by using something that uh i
tried out used and it's something that i
use i put a video on my channel here
talking about reviewing some of that and
that's like a 30
commission affiliate program so i
reason i wanted to pull up this channel
was because
um you could see that whether it's like
health whether it's books whether it's
supplements whether it's coffee
um i don't have time to go into all
these but like uh
this one was i sell coffee every single
day because of talking about do verismo
pods work
in like a cbtl pod uh deal you know it's
just crazy and
and and i really teach out of what's
happening in my life because
i got a verismo machine as a gift but i
don't want to pay the expense for the
expensive starbucks pods
so i discovered that the cbtl pods fit
found them on amazon
and then answered a question that people
were searching for and
have made hundreds of dollars of profit
um as
answering someone's question helping
them you know solve a problem and then
find a product that also worked for me
and that's kind of the essence of it
i love cbd it's it's worked for me
something that i uh that i use you know
i love shin ramen like
legit you can buy a box of shin ramen
and i made a video
all about buying bulk in amazon shin
ramen and stuff
and so uh so many different examples and
we're really gonna be breaking down some
ninja strategies a little bit later uh
as well and so hit like if you've been
getting value but this is
coffee with canal the show where i bring
you on the show
um and uh
depending on where you're watching this
in the comments people are probably
dropping you a link
to the training but again idea to income
dot tips is where i'm gonna be going
deeper into some of these trainings as
we bring
evan on my man evan how's it going bro
hey what's up
um not a ton the quarantine hasn't
really changed my life very much i'm a
homeschooler so
you know i just stayed home so my the
name of my youtube channel is evan de
dio
um e-v-a-n-d-i-d-i-o i am 16 years old
and really i've been each day in the
challenge this has been great and i
don't think people realize the power
of committing yourself to several hours
a day
just hanging out with a think media
family now i don't think people realize
because i've been watching your videos
since the fall of 2018 i think
and this challenge has kind of just put
the fire underneath me if you know what
i mean and
so i'm ready to get to work on all this
but uh so
evandio is the name of my youtube
channel actually a few weeks ago you
reviewed
um some of my thumbnails and that was
really cool
i kind of helped to get that
encouragement to know that i'm on the
right track with those but
my main question is about affiliate
marketing i have kind of two questions
today
um but as a teenager who yep that's it
right there
as a teenager who has a target audience
of teen as you can see
praise and worship team tips and tools
for teens um what is the best way that i
can monetize because
i've tried affiliate marketing and
that's i mean i'm still working on that
i use my parents account but how can i
maybe sponsorships or brand deals what
what are the ways that i should start
focusing on to
really start monetizing because i've
been doing this for two and a half years
maybe almost three years now and i'm
ready to start actually
profiting from it a little bit and
making my time
worthwhile that makes sense i love it so
you're in the perfect position to do
that first of all congrats on
you know or can like respect for your
hustle seven uploads
in the last month you know you're
growing 36 new subscribers 3 000 views
your channel is doing great and you're
at a great foundation i would recommend
everybody
build their influence first and that's
what you've done and
of course that'll continue to scale but
you're you've put in the time you've
built some trust
now is a good time to you know monetize
and i think we need to remember
that inherently monetizing is not a bad
thing like we when we monetize we are
serving people in the process when we
solve problems for them when we help
them find products and programs
um or in your case guitar pedals
strings solutions you know software
could be like
worship pad kits and all those different
things you might even look to see if
like
um some some of the digital worship pads
have affiliate programs
yeah tracks and those things they
probably do and so um
the the biggest thing though is the
types of videos
yourself is what i would say if someone
watches a cover they're probably not
going to
uh you know be in a purchasing position
if somebody watches
um religion versus true worship or the
rattle guitar
uh cover now this would be a my a video
that
would definitely uh lend itself because
if you're actually talking about a
budget
usb mic for guitarists
somebody finding this and i've got your
affiliate link there like that makes
sense in fact we even got some good
rankings happening on this video over
here that we see with vid iq
so to scale up your affiliate income you
need to be doing more of the same you
don't need to stop
any of this other content you're doing
but you should do more of the same now
a friend of mine who did some training
with us
and um has actually just not been
uploading because of other stuff in life
for about two years
still makes about a hundred dollars a
month every uh every month
completely passive income people
sometimes are like i don't believe in
passive income and i'm like i don't
believe in you
uh because like it's completely real uh
and um what he did here though that you
can see
is uh budget midi keyboards
a lot of again he was doing home studio
recording stuff sound proofing a home
studio
um and one of his big things was i think
like ableton ableton cost like 500
and it's like i think it's a 10
affiliate commission so you get 50
even if they buy it off of amazon so by
answering this question of like which
version of ableton should i get
and then you take it over here to amazon
um this is why you want to keep yourself
current but i believe
yeah this this was 4.99 499
and so you're perfectly positioned man
to do that is that making sense yeah it
is and
like that micro view that was um they've
that company has sent me two mics which
was kind of a breakthrough for me
because i realized even though i have a
small audience p brands are still
willing to invest in this so
um the affiliate marketing actually
speaking of
the challenge and going back into the
analytics i took a look the other day
into some of my top performing videos
and a review i did of the rode video mic
pro plus which i'm actually using now
that was my least favorite video of all
my videos has suddenly started to take
off and it's like
at 1500 or 1200 views now i think
and it's just i looked for the first
several weeks and thought all that video
is dead
nobody really cares about the road video
micro plus anyway but i'm thinking about
doing another video
like revised better testing for worship
leaders who are wanting to maybe record
um audio of them worshiping or whatever
because then
you know send the affiliate link and
ableton
that's something i've been wanting to
get to for a while because churches use
that all across the board
um i just need to save up to invest in
it myself to do some reviews but maybe i
can send them a message
ask them to sponsor a video or something
and get the affiliate link for that
and even your channels about the same
size are bigger already than miguel's
and people were pumped like a lot of
sound effects vst
software companies especially because
for a software company
they're really just giving you a license
so there's not even necessarily a hard
cost
to work with you as a micro influencer
and so don't underestimate
you get your branding your thumbnails
your consistency
you really have a really good
professional presence which i think are
the initial foundational ingredients
that a brand would want to see and that
i would want to get in place before
reaching out so
absolutely i'd reach out to brands
leverage some of the stuff and you'd be
surprised it looks like the office
behind you is dope man it looks like
by the way what do you want like the
depth of field of your
your setup here actually based on your
recommendations this is my bedroom
actually this is my bedroom studio i'm
just i'm starting to finish it
i mean if you look at my first videos
every video that i've shot pretty much
has been
shot in this vid in this room so i'm on
the sony a6400 with the sigma 1.4 lens
just upgraded everything using the rode
videomic pro plus
i want to upgrade that mic just got a
new computer i'm stoked about that the
asus zenbook pro duo and it is
fast my old computer was just so slow
couldn't get any editing done
like click five seconds later it
actually does something so
this can't this computer i'm actually
able to come on here with you so i'm
very excited about that but
that's what's going on here respect evan
well hey i appreciate you so much
definitely apply some of those
strategies and don't underestimate that
keyboard sitting next to you or maybe
some of the gear in your office and
doing some keyword research
because there might be some things that
you already have
that we have is the curse of knowledge
like the curse of knowledge is like i
don't know people already
understand about guitar strings no they
don't like maybe they need to know about
this guitar string versus that
guitar string like people already know
about how to
uh do this little setup or this little
upgrade to that keyboard i'm just making
this stuff up because i'm not a musician
but like there's a there's maybe even
stuff you already have and that's the
beauty of youtube i love your hustle
i love your commitment thanks so much
for being a part of the youtube
challenge and just our community in
general
and uh your setup looks fire bro i'm
like logitech webcam is put to shame
thank you very much i'm thinking about
getting the bundle today because i want
to go to grow with video live
i want to hang i want to go over to
nevada is that where it is
yeah this september i want to go over
there with my father uh actually little
kf asks one more question i don't know
if we have time for that
yeah go for it and then we've got caleb
coming up okay cool
um i'll make it quick my i've been
helping my pastor out with his youtube
channel ever since
i started following you and kind of
testing thumbnails descriptions all that
stuff on him
channel's been doing great but for
churches that have a youtube channel
what kind of trending content should
they take a look at
um doing more of yeah i mean i think
that uh for a church that's doing
youtube content
a couple things we're gonna put out is
probably just their weekend service and
their full-length message
and that's not typically gonna be
trending because you're not gonna maybe
get somebody's attention with like
a 35-45-minute message you know someone
who doesn't really know you is not gonna
have time for that i think the
the power is either sitting down and
recording content
that answers specific questions in like
a three to five minute type of a
situation or i believe the modern pastor
should be weaving in almost thinking
micro content when he's preparing his
message
for example i do think that um
youtube is a major search engine and
people are typing in all kinds of
questions
like how do i connect with god how do i
study the bible
uh what does god say about uh whatever
topic relationships dating and answering
specific
questions that can pull in people
discovering you on youtube
and then that to whatever degree you're
comfortable with and this goes
outside of even the religion world to
everybody watching whether or not
marketing or whatever
like people are afraid to be polarizing
they're afraid to
potentially tackle hard topics because
not everyone's going to agree with you
but there is something about um making a
stand and making a statement you know my
belief is
is to of course respect you know me my
vibe is it's like respect everybody but
i'm also going to stand for what i
believe in so i might
if you commentate on popular trends in
popular culture
um i think a good example of this is
there's people in our community that do
politics
politics is super you believe this or
that and sometimes people are in the
middle and they're a little bit more
moderate
but they're just not afraid to make a
statement about right or wrong or truth
and you want to talk about getting views
you get views you just
you might also get a little bit of drama
with that but i mean
you know as jesus followers jesus got a
lot of drama man
people loved or hated him people killed
him because of things he was saying
and uh we know that he rose again right
and so
nevertheless very polarizing figure he
split history
and and to this day it's like what are
people going to say about him but he was
willing
to be polarizing it's the 50 50 rule of
leadership
if if 100 of people hate you you're
probably a jerk if 100
of people like you you're probably a
people pleaser 50 50 is probably some
people go man i can vibe with that
message and some people get so offended
and upset
that they may even try and kill you and
i know that sounds extreme but i mean
this is what's happened with martin
luther king and this is what's happened
with people
in history who've stood up for strong
beliefs there's something about
you know on youtube like dude i'm not
trying to like be crazy like but
there's something about on youtube or
podcasting or whatever
and for everybody listening i'm sharing
this where you crank up what you really
believe in you're not afraid to be
polarizing you're not afraid to share a
polarizing point of view
you're not afraid to say it how you see
it to say what you stand for if you
don't stand for anything you'll fall for
anything and if you don't stand for
anything
most people won't even really follow or
resonate with you not that it's a tactic
but it actually can be a major point of
growth
to plant your flag in the sand and say
this is what i believe
this is i believe this is going wrong in
the country and the way the leaders are
doing it is wrong
and i believe this is right and think
about the people we follow we like to
follow people
who uh often times will be bold
about their beliefs and so that's kind
of like the
that crate like the most intense way to
go after it is to potentially
whatever whatever level he's comfortable
with to commentate on culture
or or or music or like injustice
or what's happening out in the world but
um a second level of that would be to
answer specific questions
um of maybe just people that are
searching for how to study the bible or
how to connect with god or how to pray
um and to make video
videos like that i'll land the plane on
this you know oftentimes we'll
label our message something like
how to have victory in the wilderness
and ain't nobody looking for like that
on youtube it's like cool title but like
what does that even mean you know like
uh the fiery trials of life and
perseverance you're like okay well like
cool title
but but it could be more practical like
how to strengthen your marriage
according to the bible you know like
like a little more straight
in marketing if you confuse you lose so
like being really bold
and just going after and just being
helpful around specific questions does
that make sense
yeah it does thank you so much for that
man this is really good
answering a lot of the questions that i
have and i know my pastor is not afraid
of stepping on some people's toes so
thank you so much for bringing me on
yeah for sure bro appreciate you thanks
for coming on
yeah i'll see you later in nevada
my man we got evan in the house we got
kayla coming up
hey uh let me know if you got value out
of that last segment
about maybe some affiliate marketing
what is your polarizing point of view
oh it's gonna get some heat in the
comments what do you believe in like
what are you willing to stand for and
look it doesn't actually necessarily
have to defend any
offend anyone maybe it's i believe that
women need a greater voice and culture i
believe
that this people group is um you know
needs to be treated more you know
correctly i believe that this
segment of society needs more awareness
or i believe this is really what i stand
for
there's something about knowing your
convictions knowing your why
knowing your reasons knowing what you're
fighting for
and there's something about willing to
put out a belief in the world
you know sometimes it could just be i
believe
that jay-z was the greatest rapper no i
believe eminem was the greatest rapper
no i believe that tupac was the greatest
rapper no it's notorious big
like you know and and you just did you
just had a four-way division man you
just
so like in i think there's something
about even in
gaming even in movies even in culture
like saying something you know something
we try to be so diplomatic and
the world is so offendable right now
like everybody is just on
glass for all these different things
like not only people share their
opinions we all should be able to but
people just get so sensitive
you can't be afraid of that in our
challenge we just talked about fopo
fear of other people's opinions
fopo you got to get over that if you're
going to build a message you're going to
like build a movement you're going to
cut through the noise you might want to
pick a side
and you might want to pick a fight not
just for fight's sake but because it's
really what you believe in
and we got kayla on the show fired up to
have you here how's it going where are
you watching from
what do you do and uh how is kind of
this pandemic thing been affecting you
i am watching can you hear me yep
okay i am watching from columbia south
america
um my husband and i are missionaries
here
and so pandemic has been a little bit
crazy
the government here has some crazy rules
and we're trying to be very respectful
of those
and unfortunately at this point churches
have not been allowed to open and
that's potentially even being extended
for another six months and so there's
there's lots of things they're talking
about nothing is certain yet
at this point it's at least until may
25th and so
during pandemic we decided that we still
wanted to do
ministry and so we created a youtube
channel
in march and the moment i created the
youtube channel i started researching
how do you do this
and found your channel right off the bat
and i had listened to two or three other
creators that talk about
how to grow your youtube best practices
but
one of the things that stuck out to me
about you was your faith and so
um jumped on board and started watching
your
your videos and then joined the youtube
channel last week
and have seen lots of good growth we're
definitely still a small channel
but it's fun to be able to not only
share those videos here in columbia
but it's now getting viewed in argentina
in spain
and in the united states as well so we
started creating it in both
english and spanish to fit those two two
people groups
and just letting god's word be heard
that's amazing now are you doing
both languages on the same channel yeah
that was actually one of my questions
so we do both languages on the channel
but i have them in two separate
playlists and then
every video what i've started doing at
least in these last
two three videos that i've uploaded is
in the first five seconds i say
if you're looking for this link in
english and i put the link up above in a
card
or if it's my english video if you're
looking for it in spanish i put the card
up above so that they can
bounce if they get to the wrong one but
i don't know if you would recommend
starting two channels i mean that seems
like a huge
huge task um from the start but we do
have english and spanish on the same
channel
okay so um yeah that's a great first
question and thank you for everything
you're doing
and way to pivot and adapt in the midst
of the lockdown that's as you know kind
of been our message
that thank god for live streaming
cameras the internet like we're in such
an era of being able to still
communicate and impact people
um i have a video out on what language
your youtube channel should be in and
i'm going to put it up on screen just so
people can watch it later and i'll kind
of break down what the
principles are of it but it's how to
choose the best language for your
youtube channel is the video
and what i essentially talk about in the
video is
here's the quote for youtube you never
want to upload
a video that your subscribers didn't
subscribe for
so let's say that again you never want
to upload a video that your subscribers
didn't subscribe for
and and the reason why is because the
way the youtube algorithm works
is um it is
always trying to you release a new video
you've got 10 subscribers 100
subscribers it's going to kind of
release it to them
first via probably the browse page and
if they even know about subscriptions
and if they click on it or not it's then
going to say
okay your subscribers liked it let's
even send it to more of your subscribers
and then eventually youtube will go okay
people who are not subscribed but are
like your
subscribers will be presented this via
suggested videos or browse features and
have a chance to click on it as well
so even thinking about you being on
mission with a message if you
want a video to spread on youtube you
kind of want to think through that
process it needs to strike a chord it
needs to
resonate but even just from the
standpoint of never uploading a video
your subscribers didn't subscribe for
if i click subscribe on your channel um
because i want to learn from you in
english
every single time you upload a video in
a different language it's really not
for me now you are
kind of doing a disclaimer but what's
happening is you're just sort of
constantly mixing the audience and i
think that
that becomes just tough it's kind of
like if you confuse you lose
and it kind of could confuse the youtube
algorithm and
um and limit the growth of your channel
from a practical standpoint it makes
sense
depending on your macro vision of the
channel you could still do it because
you are communicating and kind of cross
promoting those videos
but if you're uploading two videos
anyways i almost feel like it's two
different channels does that make sense
yep and honestly we have started
uploading twice a week
and so we're actually doing four videos
because we do it in spanish and english
each time
but i guess what you're saying it
wouldn't be any more work
because we're already uploading them so
it would just be on two different
channels instead of instead of in the
same so that does
definitely help me i really really
appreciate that that tidbit of advice
and i'd love to answer another question
but let me just give you one other
thought is that you also want to
condition youtube
about what your channel is about as much
as possible that's called like building
channel authority
meaning your titles your tags your
metadata your descriptions the content
that your videos are about
you want it to like season the youtube
algorithm so youtube goes okay this is
what
that person is known for because then
that also helps youtube even distribute
your content more again if you confuse
youtube
can you break these rules sure you can
do whatever you want but
um if again you're giving them in a way
two different metadatas of titles
and tags even that is a level of
confusing the youtube algorithm there's
something
there's a channel called five minute
crafts which is this massive
channel that has like five minute crafts
teen in in these different channels
they also have different versions of the
videos in different languages
but they're entirely different channels
so that each one
gets to connect with that audience and
that community
and doesn't cross contaminate in a way
audiences confusing the algorithm and
everything else
absolutely that is super helpful my only
other question
that wasn't answered in the challenge
because let me tell you that challenge
was
super all-inclusive um we
live in colombia and so the houses here
are made
of concrete it's cinder blocks with
concrete so i have concrete ceiling
concrete floors concrete walls
we try to cover it when we film with
pillows and blankets
but we get a lot of echo so i'm looking
at buying a microphone
but what would be best in a closed boxed
in
concrete situation to reduce that echo
but give a good
sound quality would it be a lavalier mic
would it be
what kind of i don't know camera do you
want to plug the microphone into
yeah we need to we need to upgrade our
cameras too so right now we are using
a cute acti now not even a brand name
we're using we're using what the church
has here so we're using what we got
um that's gonna be the next step but i
know microphones are less expensive and
so we could
even hook it to my laptop and not have
it go through the camera
give us something that's the boom mic i
guess that came with the camera
but that boom mic is it came with an 80
camera purchase so there's your quality
so we just talked about this today in a
little uh update
inside of the youtube influence
challenge group and this is the samsung
q2u 70 69.99
on the us amazon so of course i'm sure
getting resources could be challenging
but maybe there's also people who ship
things to you
um and they do indeed yeah so
um we will uh in fact
we'll send you one of these so i'll have
melissa just email hello at
seancannell.com
and this might not be the only mic you
need so that way you could also invest
in something else if you want so
if you'll do that just email uh email us
and uh
say you're on coffee with canel and then
we'll send you one of these here's the
power of this mic
is um is you can plug it into your
laptop or a tablet
or a smartphone even it's harder to plug
it into
a camera's audio input because it does
need
power and so it's really going to be
more for like
live streaming or creating off your
laptop or as you said you could record
the audio separate
um on your laptop film yourself and then
maybe edit those things together
but i think that almost everybody
watching um
needs this setup as well it's basically
what we're doing you know what i mean
zoom calls
stream yard is the software we're using
right now i'm i'm
live on youtube as well as facebook
multi-streaming
and i'm using a usb mic and we just did
a test and a lot of people thought this
one sounded better at 70
than this 200 one uh but uh the debate
raises on with tony
who we always debate about condenser
versus dynamic but
um we'll send you that
and you got me too
you want to thank you so much for being
a part of uh our community
and and this though is what the one that
i didn't even get to the point one of
the reasons why i recommend this
is because a dynamic mic that's kind of
this setup
um really cuts out noise we use mics
like this
in conference floors when we do
interviews and all that kind of stuff
and uh it cuts out noise all around
in like music blaring so in an echo we
room
it'll still be really forgiving and so
um
that is the opportunity of this mic and
so you'll be able to use that in
multiple ways the next thing i'd
recommend
is like a boya by m1 that
i think that little camcorder you you
have uh has a mic
input right and it does yeah so
we we talk about this lab all the time
it's gonna help
uh to your point like when you plug in a
lav mic
um if it's an echoey room it's this will
probably pick that up at least you'll be
closer because it'll be on your shirt
and there's like twenty dollars so uh
yeah this is part of your kit would be
a good way to go and the only other like
kind of hack around
would be we um we're at a conference for
think marketing
and video influencer shooting interviews
on this channel and um
we use a zoom h1 which is an external
audio recorder
and either record the audio separate
which you could do on your laptop with a
microphone like this
or with like a headphone jack we connect
the mic
through to um
uh what do you call it like here we go
so we connect the mic through out of the
headphone jack of the
zoom portable audio recorder and you
could look up this type of gear later
and uh we had these two wired mics
plugged into two mics in the
zoom recorder and then we were recording
on the camcorder and these same idea
these are sure a lot of like worship
teams would use these mics they're like
the sm-58s or whatever
and um they are sound amazing and they
too will cut out a lot of that echoey
noise
so you can this will be the replay of
this will be up and you can always check
that out and
check out some of those uh product names
and whatnot that i recommended but
uh email us so we can get you uh this
shipped out to you
um and then look up some of those other
mics as you're upgrading your
your stuff but i love that you've
already taken action and you've realized
come on you gotta you know it's the
content value that matters more than the
production value and we can always
upgrade the production value as we go
absolutely well thank you for your time
thank you guys for putting so much
effort
into into the challenge our channel even
in the last week grew i think by 16
subscribers
so i mean we're small but it was a great
it was a great start to start putting in
some of those
those action pieces so thank you i love
it kayla god bless thank you so much for
uh what you're doing and what your
family's doing
to impact the world and um thanks for
being part of this challenge and
everything else
and look forward to staying connected
and seeing how your journey progresses
thank you hey this is coffee with
cannell the show
where we bring on you let me know what
you're drinking today i got the ryzen
grind mug
uh been sipping on some coffee gonna be
tackling
a renew daily greens celery cucumber
green juice here
and i'm also drinking some x-lite
electrolytes because i threw down
only about two and a half miles today
before the day got started my friends
we just got done with a seven day it's
really about a nine day once it was all
said and done
uh youtube challenge streamed for over
30 hours
but we're still going and i've got a
free training coming up tonight before i
crash into a wall and into the weekend
uh no we actually have we're finishing
strong and it's been so amazing to be
able to connect with people like evan
and people like kayla
and people like you if you were part of
the challenge um it's over
now but what is cool is we do have
this um training coming up uh which
is um uh when you're watching this idea
to income dot tips
it's a limited training on how i use one
simple strategy to turn 130 dollars into
over 13 000 with a single youtube video
and so um if you're just joining
at the beginning we talked about
different ways to monetize i'm gonna be
breaking some of that down
on a free training in actually just a
few hours so if you want to register for
that register for that
um and i'm excited to jump in with a few
more people
today and so coming up next we've got
stefan did i say your name right stephen
stephen my man welcome to
the show where are you streaming from
what's
like your business or channel and how's
this pandemic affected you
okay so i'm a musician my channel is
uh stephen cox base and um
basically it took away all my the
pandemic took away all my gigs
so i was already doing youtube for about
the past i don't know more than 10 years
about as long as you've been on and um
and i just have to take it more
seriously now so i'm using it to
generate leads for
skype lessons i'm doing affiliate links
with
product reviews which i've been doing
for the last three years and um
uh what else am i doing patreon so
patreon is probably the biggest
biggest source of income at the moment
and i'm just trying to figure out yeah
what i can do
looking looking at my page you can tell
i need to upgrade some stuff update some
stuff
but um i just i just ordered an m50
camera and i just became a member of um
video ranking academy so i'm trying to
figure out what to do
to essentially double my income
right now and i know that's how i should
make now probably
off of youtube 400 a month
between four and 500 a month okay so
and uh lessons probably maybe 300 a
month or so via skype
yeah so we need to go to
from 700 or 800
to 1600
uh yeah my my expenses are 1700 really
so
yeah basically got it what is your
biggest flow right now
the biggest flow i'm trying to get
people to convert from youtube and
patreon
to skype and so i'm looking into
marketing i
actually bought a course a few years ago
well i think was last year
on marketing that and so they have ideas
on facebook ads and things like that
but i also think that the product
reviews have been doing a lot lately and
with this giant boost
my highest earning video
is um a product review i did on an
instrument called a ubase
with metal strings and i'm pretty much
the main person in that niche
meaning like i do ubase versus upright
bass i do
ubase versus all sorts of things and
there are other people doing it but they
aren't doing weekly videos and so i
pretty much like own the niche
so i know i need to upgrade my um
channel background
to include you base more than the other
ones
and then um with patriot with patreon
it's
it's making me a little less than 300 a
month so i'm just trying to kind of
got it got it all that stuff all right
well yeah let's break it down so
you said it yourself you said the the
shortest path and here's a question for
everybody watching two
define this answer this question what is
your shortest
path to revenue like your shortest path
the product reviews are amazing and they
can compound and eventually be even more
passive
but they're probably not the shortest
path patreon also
need you need a bigger audience and a
percentage of that audience want to
support you
but it's probably not your shortest path
and you already identified for me if i
can book
skype calls how many skype calls is that
like a month uh
that would just fill your pipeline let's
see um
i'm about to raise my rates back up to
full i had you know lowered the rates
for um
for being stuck at home and that got a
few students but what i realized is most
of them decided to pay the full price
anyway like they know i'm undercutting
myself
so what's the full price so i'm doing 30
for 30 minute lesson basically and then
if they're a patron they get a five
dollar discount on every lesson
so i'm not advertising that outside of
patreon because i want
you know do you have any bundles not yet
um but somebody did just buy you know
i'm telling them that the prices are
going back up
at the end of may so it's kind of like
if you buy in advance
then you can um you can get the price
now
for however far out you schedule lessons
what do i buy where do you buy it okay
so it links uh most of the videos have a
link in the description that go to a
landing page that's kind of terrible
right now
um i think all my recent ones have it on
there that says for skype lessons or
whatever maybe i need to work that
better maybe it's you know i'm not good
at like the copyright
kind of thing i want to learn how to do
that and my site definitely is updating
that was actually today's
today's look because the the branding is
from an album i released in 2017 with a
picture of atlanta in the background
yes yeah okay so i love this so so
here's what i would do
so a couple things and you're you're
definitely leaning into the right
way of thinking okay so first thing is
identifying
what is the mission fill pipeline with
clients
uh so that you can you know pay your
bills working from home
okay and then so then that becomes and
directs your energy to say okay the
thing i should do more than anything
else
is get clients and get customers
seventeen hundred dollars a month
divided by thirty dollars
is 56 students a month okay
um but six lessons right maybe six
lessons lessons yes
so um so then you you could take that
number
and this is what everybody watching you
should do your math pull out a piece of
paper like what you need to hit your
target
could be like how much ad revenue could
be whatever but what's cool here
is we've actually got this all broken
down so we're going to go 56 divided by
you know 31 it's only two lessons a day
um and of course you want to book out
and be
uh booked out you know further so so
you're
it is as far as possible i've done some
of this too like i have my minimum real
numbers to sustain myself
and so i have about 500 with youtube
over here yeah with lessons they need to
make 1200.
so uh if i do 20 average lessons which
is kind of this like discounted rate
i would need 15 lessons a week if i did
a 25 average where i'm netting
netting 25 or something sure i got you
but i i would also
i want to i want to exceed that i want
to definitely
and a book i would recommend for you is
and everybody watching
if you haven't read the 10x rule by
grant cardone who's definitely a sales
guy
love him or hate him he's got kind of an
interesting personality right
but but the 10x rule is this you got to
set higher targets
like you gotta have so you gotta
actually take
this this is this will be a major
mindset shift
well okay i do wanna say that i tried to
do a hundred thousand
the other year and i made too big of a
thing and i felt like i failed on my
goal
so i've done that mindset before
thought about the big numbers and i've
written all this out and actually have a
spreadsheet on it and i think i set too
big of a goal and it actually
demotivated me okay well let me break it
down because this is maybe not
necessarily connected to motivation you
don't want to connect it to
your self-worth or anything like that
you connect it here's the secret to the
10x rule
you connect it to your actions and your
behaviors
and your thinking so what you do is if
you need 1700 a month which what you're
thinking
wants to be is 17 000 a month
because the power of the 10x rule is
that changes the whole game
you could you would all you would be
incapable with your amount of time to
get there
so the question is like oh do i raise my
prices um
do i do i bundle like you just you have
to think different
that's the power of just and here's the
cool thing about
shooting for the stars you might hit the
moon if you say okay
i'm actually going to reverse engineer
my daily actions my daily goals my daily
habits
and the things that i need to do in
order to hit 17
000 if you only hit 3
153 at the end of the month you just
doubled your current target and that's
just the initial thing i'd want you to
think about rather than even thinking
how do i reach 1700 yes it's practical
it's literally how do i reach 17 000 and
then not like beating yourself
up if you still only hit like 800 like
fine but
then it's it's it's 10x goals but it's
also 10x actions let me give you a list
we gotta fix the page because you gotta
you have more people that land on the
page
they also they need more marketing in a
good way like
what's in it for them you need to be
speaking to another good book would be
building a story brand
uh what is it going to feel like when i
can play
the way i envision myself in my head
what is it going to feel like when i now
have the
confidence what is it going to feel like
when i get promoted and banned what is
it going to feel like
um and really building out a page you
got to have clearer
offers like the offers got to be really
clear in terms of
um this is exactly what you get you got
to think about bonuses you think about
here you're getting this
but in addition to that you're also
going to get my quick start video series
this is a lot to create but you don't
necessarily create that all at once of
course
and i'm just it's like i'm overwhelming
myself with a whole bunch of things and
i
i agree with you that i got to like
build it bring it down to skype
and then once it's sustaining me then i
can kind of like branch out and do this
did you already have a course
um i don't have it finished and i'm
getting in you know i'm getting an
m50 and i want to upgrade my videos
because my light
my um videos all flicker because i'm
using a camera phone
and i've gotten kind of tired of that
i've got good audio on them but
the but the lighting just flickers all
the time
okay so yeah so i'm getting the m50 and
then i've got to get better lighting
this little construction mic i'm using
is
interesting but the glare and all the
other stuff is ridiculous i still got to
watch your video on getting rid of glare
with the
better lights but yeah um but it's hard
to spend money right now because i'm not
i'm not really sustaining myself without
the like government help that happened
and i got you so i'm not saying i'm
actually saying that you need to send
money i mean you could
you don't have to get those books or
just put those books on the back shelf
i'm kind of breaking it down now
here's another way to like work on your
sales pages or your offer pages
who are five to ten other
people that are hitting the amount of
skype calls and trainings that have
beautiful pages
and remember that picasso said and steve
jobs said
um quoting picasso that good artist copy
great artists steal god gave you eyes
plagiarized okay i'm not actually saying
plays your eyes disclaimer
everybody but go to somebody who
who hired a copywriter for fifteen
thousand dollars to build their sales
page
and be like oh that's a good sentence
i'll use that i'll change these few
words well that's a cool way he laid it
out or that's a cool way
and so that's some free hustle work you
could do uh russell brunson would call
that funnel hacking like just like
grabbing somebody else's funnel um and
so just a couple things though you got
to get your
offer dialed in you got to get your
offer desirable and then you got to fill
your pipeline and and i would 10 extra
actions you don't need to read the book
like
17 000 is the new sneaking target going
on it works like
cheaper right now because or maybe i
missed the chance yeah there's actually
he gives it away free
you know you pay shipping there's like
an upsell but like yeah you pay like
seven bucks or
i mean it's worth reading because i
think but like all i'm saying is
reverse engineer backwards from what it
would take to make 17 000
and and let's come back to i'm not
suggesting you're not working hard
but when you're in a situation where
your life depends on it
you gotta freaking grind bro you know
what i mean like i you know
maybe my story from my wife being in the
hospital and
me working i would work at red robin
thursday friday and saturday
while working at my church and trying to
build my business
and i would work 36 hours in those three
days i know everybody has different
capacity or whatever
but like we can't be timid especially
when it's hard times to like
really grind it's the one thing i've got
right now is a bunch of time
yeah so putting the time tweaking it you
know emailing people back
not pushing but like going after it like
not hesitating getting in that confident
mentality and i think that's
that's the thing is like you know what
you have can help people being involved
in i mean there's so many things
you want to focus your energy but like
where are your customers
like where are they in facebook groups
what kind of things are they looking for
and the last thing i would say is when i
look at your website or rather your
youtube page okay are you giving call to
actions to
it in in the videos in the video um
yes for patreon and other things but not
for skype except for one or two times i
tested it out kind of
you know so here's the deal if you want
to live streams i'm going live on
saturday too so
okay if you want to sell something you
have to make
offers like you know what i mean like
you have to actually put it
out and i get it it's so weird to sell
and it's whatever but it's your ethical
duty to sell
because from looking at you you've got
you know your stuff you can teach people
you can help testimonial back from one
of my students and hearing what they
were saying back
let me know that i do have something
valuable that it was really something
they needed
oh by the way video testimonials you
need video testimonials on youtube
i've got one so i'm planning on get that
out there
and then again you can like your income
will be directly correlated
to the amount of value you put in the
marketplace your free videos your free
value
but it'll also be directly correlated to
the amount of offers you make
it's value and it's make an offer people
can do whatever they want but it's value
and it's making an offer
and so i people need to hear about it
more i think
again if we want we have this target two
a day
and we just alone because then check it
out the recipe gravy
all this other stuff would be great if
we could do two a day that'll fill up
your pipeline every single day
and it'll hit the 1700 target so now
we'd be almost
closer to 2200 2500 um with momentum
coming in
and so the final thing i'll say just so
we can use
the time to hit a few more people before
i have a coaching call as well okay
is uh is i want you thinking and
building out your systems this is a
sales process
and systems like do you already have
calendly and stuff set up
what is that no like a way for people to
book the times with you
no they just have to go back and forth
and stuff right now they just email me
times and i get back to them same day
and yeah so you got you need systems bro
like you know what i'm saying so you
so it's a whole different level of
thinking it's the scale of thinking
i'm going to have more clients than i
can deal with it's not just going to be
the 52
i'm going to have 104. so i need them
coming in
and then your sales page is like here's
what you'll do you'll sign up
you'll book a time with me you'll
schedule the time you'll get you know
this extra and and there's some stuff
you could do without creating something
new maybe it's like
some music you've done maybe it's just
some training or maybe it's probably all
the patreon page
the stuff i give patrons like yeah
you're like i'm going to give you a few
bonus things from the patreon page when
you enroll in this
that's called creating an offer and so
you make that irresistible
and then and then you need more than one
option one option is 30 minute dollars
for 30 minutes
or you know 60
and maybe 30 bucks off for two or
something like four rather
maybe you go ninety dollars for four
or a hundred dollars for four and that's
twenty bucks off it's a round number
being left up anywhere or is that like
does this is this
does this stream disappear or does this
get no it'll be left up okay good
because i'm going to need to go back to
it like 10 minutes
so so you so then that's a and that
should also be irresistible i can get
the hour with you
or i can get the four sessions for that
higher price and now
now i only need 17 100 clients
that grab those four sessions with me
that's seventeen hundred dollars
and then four times 17 i'm not very good
at math off the top of my head
would by you know four times 17
four times yeah because the four
sessions would be the 68 sessions
so that'd be the fulfillment every month
of a couple a day
and then with the rest of your time that
day and here's the goal this is this
gonna happen instantly no you gotta
grind
but you need to be giving more calls to
action i could see it being on your page
people don't know what exists man they
they need like a website up here they
need to know how they can do business
with you
they need an about page some text here
that's saying
you get a lot of free stuff and whatnot
if you want to go to another level
here's how you go to another level
breaking it all down for them and and
even if it meant your videos slowed down
at first following up maybe if you have
emails or with your patreon people or
or putting up a video like just do a
video or do a live stream and say
get this stuff dialed but then do a live
stream and say
man i'm so pumped i'm excited to
announce that i'm doing these trainings
and you can see it below it's 30 bucks
for one but it's actually i'm doing a
package you get
four of them for a hundred dollars and
here's what you get you get time with me
here check
out this video you play the video
testimonial and you give a call to
action
some of your videos on a low are getting
200 people so you get in front of 200
people
10 of those people want to do it you
fill your pipeline with 20
you're already getting some momentum and
you work on delivering getting more
video testimonials
hitting that financial target and then
you use your extra
time to double down on the product
revenue and the momentum of
of affiliates and even patreon and all
the things stack
but let's land the plane on shortest
path to revenue
knowing what your sales process is
knowing what
you know dialing in that offer page and
then don't i know it's overwhelming
because maybe you can't invest in like
the best
new website or something but you can use
better words you can
research five to ten competitors borrow
some of their
headlines and their offer and whatnot
and bundle these things together you
could find
a free scheduling software or some kind
of a google form
and brick by brick put the thing
together is that you're gonna be problem
free of course not entrepreneurs
sign up for one problem after a next
fixing this fixing that page
solving the problem answering the
customer answering the complaint but
it's all good
and just build that thing out man i
believe in you and i think that
did you get some value out of this today
this is this is incredible
i think this is gonna like add so much
to it you pointed out the things this is
what i needed
point out the things that need to be
changed first if you gave me one action
step today
what would you do first
off and start selling dial in that offer
i mean i might
the first thing i would do is dial in
the offer a little bit
and go live or shoot a video today and
post it on your youtube channel and
invite people to come do your coaching
i would sell the coaching sell the
coaching like immediately i try to get
like 10 clients
in the next 24 hours really
so not wait till saturday's live stream
to do that but do that
today you think yeah you don't have to
be nervous like i'm
super excited to come into it on
saturday you know what i mean like
people know about it once
you pitch it on saturday re-pitch it
okay
again add some like hey just want to
throw this out there
some people a lot of you just didn't
know that i
do skype based training link in the
description below
here's the offer and then just jump
right in
this your shortest path and that's the
killer mentality that i want you to have
michael jordan you know the last dance
you're probably not a sports guy is that
true
not much of a sports car either am i
actually i like basketball
like i don't even know like people are
watching this documentary i do want to
watch it though
but uh they always talked about like his
mentality and and that's
there's something about getting in that
confident state here's what i want to
speak into you as we land the plane
steven
you have a great product to help people
you've invested in your craft you've
invested in guitar you've already gotten
people resolved you've got a glowing
video it's testimonial
um to sell is to serve and
you're i can tell by your spirit you're
not like twisting anybody's arm you're
not being weird
they don't have to sign up for you but
you have to let them know
about the opportunity to sign up with
you and let's land the plane for the
whole think media community and think
marketing
there used to be the law of 7 in
marketing that in order for somebody to
do business with you they needed to be
exposed to the offer seven
times because the world is so busy that
law
has been eviscerated it is not even kind
of
a 2020 law google uh
think with google did a study that said
it now takes
like 21 to 26 touch points
of people being exposed to what it is
you sell
what how it is you can help them
explaining it breaking it down
and so this does not mean like pushy
push it just means
people need to know what it is they got
questions and they go yeah i did wanted
to get into base training but then they
got distracted and then they got a fight
with their spouse and then their kid
came in and kicked the coffee cup onto
their lap so
so just realizing and weaving in those
messaging points of how people can be
do business with you and not be afraid
and i think what also happens is we have
fopo fear of other people's opinions
as soon as you sell something people are
gonna get offended
there's always gonna be like five
percent of people that are like wow now
the video is free anymore
and that's not who you're trying to
reach you know your heart you know you
love
people you're an ethical dude you're
here to serve you're not twisting
anybody's arm
you know what i mean but there's always
going to be somebody you can't let that
one percent
negative critical like kind of entitled
in gra in gratitude type of a person
like that's dude you've got free videos
on your website like crazy like you've
been adding value
serving people like and so if anybody
misunderstands that
like blessings to them like maybe that
probably has to do with their
their past trauma or their perspective
but like
you're not gonna force anyone to sign up
for a skype training with you
you just need to let them know that it
exists and
and realize that people aren't even
hearing you they're busy like whatever
google told us it's taken like 21 to 26
touch points
in marketing messaging to get people to
like buy a pair of jeans that's why the
genes follow you around the internet
with retargeting
and so uh does that help today man that
helps so much
thank you so much cool bro hey i
appreciate you thanks so much for coming
on the show
and uh keep crushing it man i'm excited
to see you take action on all this
thank you appreciate it sean take care
hey
coffee with kennel look i think we have
time for like one or more two more here
um and i hope you're getting value
though but drop an aha moment from
somebody else's session
whether you're watching this on facebook
whether you're watching this
on youtube did you get any unlocks for
what you need to do
next did you feel uh disrupted a little
bit by
maybe man i i should uh step out a
little bit more be a little bit more
bold with my message
can you relate to fopo um you know to
sell
is to serve and some people will
misunderstand that but you can't have
fear of other people's opinions man
you don't want to give too much credit
to the praise or the haters
you just got to know you know your heart
you know that you love people you know
your ethics you know your values
and people are going to misunderstand
you people misunderstand everybody
people got
opinions about everybody cool i respect
your opinions i got opinions too
i got an opinion about you awesome
and so man you got to be bold you're on
a mission and you got to fight for your
family like no hesitation
i saw somebody say uh in our private
trap back here with some of the people
on deck
uh don't put off till tomorrow what you
can do today
during this pandemic man you gotta grind
and i do wanna recommend
um we put out a video that's kind of no
video influencers our channel is really
not about like leadership and things
like that
uh but we the video is called 17 hacks
for creating your best content
during quarantine but really it's about
the 17 mentalities
of being a wartime leader and you might
be like
what's that i'm just content creator but
like but it's really about
like overcoming apathy uh rising up
and really leading right now by the way
if you're a content creator you're a
thought leader if you're a content
creator
you know you're putting your voice your
message into the world and so this is
like 37 minutes
where benji and i break down like 17
different attributes and 17 ways to get
motivated create better content
so that's brand new on video influencers
highly recommend that
uh i saw katie say to cells to serve
in the comment back here and so let's
bring katie on
and uh see whoa
yeah he hangs out with me he's pretty
cool
that's awesome katie hey tell me where
you're watching from what's your
business
and how's this kind of pandemic thing
affected you so i'm in gilbert
arizona and i'm in the business with
horses i teach horseback riding lessons
and what's called equine assisted
learning which is mental health-based
sessions for
special needs so when the pandemic first
hit we have a lot of immunocompromised
people so we kind of fell
flat but now that the world is opening
back up i'm seeing a lot more clientele
come through
do you have a youtube channel or what's
your channel called
it's called equine feather us how do i
spell that equine feather like equine e
q
u i n e f e a t h e
r and then space u s
um it's a pretty recent channel it only
has a handful of videos
30 subscribers e-q-u-i-n-e
heather yeah like a bird feather got it
got it got him okay awesome so what's
your question today
um so i mean basically my channel
is kind of just recently started um
i'm kind of wondering how to target
local people because the really cool
thing about this channel is i've already
gotten one
in person client who has found me
through youtube
i have no idea how she found me
considering you know how small the
channel is
um but that's kind of what i'm looking
at is targeting
equestrians in my community because
that's the my main service is them
coming in taking lessons
training their horse i love it so
that's crazy though you're telling me
you already got one client
you just started yep you got 30
subscribers and they came and worked
with you locally
they said they found the youtube video
yeah they said that they
were researching horses on youtube and
stumbled across my channel and binge
watched everything and then they
signed up for a couple months of lessons
so she's coming to me once a week for a
lesson
that's amazing and friends uh
watching this whether live or on the
replay that's the power of youtube man
31 subscribers in
uh i think you just got another
subscriber probably from that's going
live here because i think we just bumped
up one
and um that's awesome and so uh
okay a couple things i would say you
know i love this question about
like local business you know how to use
youtube for local business like versus
you know um like what you could do
wider than that and i think the
mentality you should have
is not local but the awareness you want
to point to
is local so let me give you one example
we do a thing called vegas influencers
here in
uh vegas if people want to check it out
i think you can sign up
we're not meeting right now because the
pandemic but eventually we will again
vegasinfluencers.com so
think about that and even what i just
did here on think marketing and whatnot
like people are
aware of it the majority of people shout
me out where are you watching from let
me know in the comments
are not in vegas but what's been so
crazy as your influence grows
on youtube is that like over 50 people
probably now
have come to vegas influencers now
that's a free meetup that we do
monthly during normal times and it's led
to a lot of business
so i think there's an opportunity for
you to take on the mentality of i could
see even just your thumbnails by the way
look great
it looks like momentum you're already
doing like everything looks really great
so
um it looks obviously you're able to
create content
it looks like you were smart there even
in starting with like a cool
moment and then maybe cutting back into
the content so you've got some intuition
and and definitely
seem to be doing some things right and
um
all of that is like super super awesome
my wife sonia is going to love this
channel too
um you've got end cards and stuff so
yeah like you really
um i think what i would do though is i
would like be thinking about building a
big brand
answering kind of like global questions
answering
helpful questions and always bringing
back awareness like
you could say in a few sentence like
where a queen feather
u.s we're based here in arizona we love
but today
and when you sow that the bigger your
brand gets
then it's that individual who's like
wait a minute they're like they're local
potentially
or you can become a destination probably
another 20
people that have come to vegas
influencers have come because vegas is a
destination
when they're in town they're like dude i
don't even know and it happened vegas is
quite a few conventions and whatnot
but nevertheless someone's like man when
i visit i might want to visit one time
so it's kind of a mentality shift
and i think that also is a shift and
this goes for all of us as business
owners and entrepreneurs
that there are ways to create multiple
streams of income eventually
i mean eventually could it could be like
an online course or it could be
something related to even the business
of what you're doing or even helping
others launch that
uh even from the mental health side or
like whatever
and it could be resources or e-commerce
and not that that's your ambition
but we're living in a world where we
need diversity as you saw
the lockdown happened your customers
slowed down the question becomes
what is your online offer the question
becomes
what do you have for sale online the
question becomes
how is your business diversified and the
cool thing
is this could be a life-changing moment
on coffee with kennel
because you building that out maybe
isn't in the next
two weeks it might be in the next four
years but
you start chipping away at it and start
thinking okay and the whole time
you're having fun put videos on youtube
building your influence on youtube
adding goodwill getting to know people
as well as thinking about what your
future
uh potential online uh offer could be
uh you know again eventually it could be
like affiliate marketing best
accessories
uh for for horses and and um
tackle like diy like maybe how to build
a
you know i'm just kind of some different
ideas that like globally some people
could really be into
and and let me bring up one of our
students
uh that kind of i think speaks to this
to illustrate the mentality so stone
coat countertops
um are they do epoxy countertops
and so that's countertops that kind of
look like stone but are made much more
affordable with epoxy
and this is mike and he um
their youtube channel gets like 4
million views a month so by the way
and it's it's had as many as 10 million
views a month
and that's literally like 50 to 100 000
at certain times in youtube ad revenue
like that's the idea of building a big
brand in terms of and you know that
might be
sounds crazy but like there's a lot of
people around the world that would maybe
want to watch horse stuff so you start
thinking that way
but then um they actually have an
e-commerce store
where you can buy this and do it
yourself
so i should go back and say they install
the countertops
for people locally so they have a
brick-and-mortar
mortar local business but then they also
uh have the videos in the youtube ad
revenue but then they also sell
the e-commerce stuff on their website
table
epoxy etc all the different things
and if you actually study out their
business they've got about 10 different
income streams
that is not i mean it's probably a
little overwhelming you're like
slow down i could tell you had a little
extra coffee today sean
as usual uh but like i mean that's
a it's a lot but that's like the next
one two
three four five years that would be the
way i'd be thinking about your youtube
channel
and you don't have to do any of those
things or you could do all of those
things
and it's really break by brick because
you start getting a little ad revenue
i don't know if you have like a family
member or a sister or a friend or an
intern they start helping you create
more videos
you start making more a little bit more
momentum with the videos
you put out a couple like product review
type
horse product where you work with a
company that makes saddles and some
different things
and just you start is deving your way up
and then more revenue comes so you could
build a bigger team if that's your
ambition
yeah and that's really where the youtube
channel could could grow to
that is what i would do if i was you
looking at the quality of the content
you're you're putting out looking at
your energy on camera
and then just thinking about the biggest
struggle we all all are going to have
this is what our think marketing channel
is all about
is you got to be get known the only way
i could ever like you
and eventually do business with you
business works from know like and trust
is they need to actually know who you
are first
so we want to go wide with youtube
content we want to go wide
with awareness right we want to go wide
with
um and youtube channel gives us the
opportunity to do that
even if there's sort of a global
audience reach or a u.s
wide reach mentality big things start
small
the huge oak tree starts as just a seed
form
um and then eventually that oak tree
though supplies
shade and abundance you know for
generations
um and so i think that's that's a big
level of thing for your youtube channel
but then i would think you'd have
as many local clients as you need of
course there could be other online
marketing strategies when i think local
sometimes i think youtube's like a brand
almost like a portfolio almost like uh
something for people to look at locally
on your website like wow
they connect with you we just did i
think marketing episode with stephanie
liu who said
one of the power of video is it actually
when people look in our eyes and they
connect with us on video and we talk to
them and add value
it releases oxytocin in the brain
which is the feel good chemical and so
when a business owner
a real estate agent a horse trainer or
somebody who does
horse tours or something again wants to
eventually
connect with customers um video is the
best
way to do it because it's an accelerator
of just getting to know people
and eventually your pipeline will be so
full quote unquote it's a sales term
right but like your pipeline
is so full that um i think you could not
just create a lot of online abundance
but also have plenty of people coming to
you
uh locally in arizona as well does that
make sense and is that valuable
yeah that's beautiful i love that thank
you so much
um yeah i know it definitely makes sense
to kind of reach out far and wide
and then have you know local people come
on through
i love the tree comparison that you use
because that's kind of what it feels
like is it feels like i've planted the
seed and it's starting to sprout
and i can definitely see the potential
that youtube has i love it katie i
really appreciate that you came on what
was your bird's name again
pluto pluto that's the first
bird we've had on coffee with cam does
pluto talk her now
um sometimes he sings but he's really
shy okay he's probably
camera shy like a lot of us shout out
like shy to get on camera just like
pluto well hey
kati i appreciate you thanks so much for
coming on with coffee with kennel and
i'm excited to see how your channel
grows and uh love the vibe you already
have there
where did you get your skills like you
the videos you already have out the
thumbnails the videos the quality
start from nowhere um so i've been
making youtube videos since i can
remember
i've had channels that have been about
everything and anything so
obviously none of them took off it was
just recently that i saw the value
in having a niche and having a very
specific market that i'm like all right
this is my channel this is what i'm
going with and i'm all in with the
horses i always have been
and yeah now it's i think it's built a
really good foundation for this channel
so how many other channels have you had
and probably how many videos have you
posted before
i've had at least five or six other
channels and i've posted hundreds and
hundreds of videos
um like i've been all over the place i
used to do like vegan recipe videos
hiking
outdoors self-improvement
that kind of stuff so i'm really glad
you shared that i had a hunch
and i wanted everyone in our community
to hear that because
you i want to compliment and just say
it's so inspiring to see your resilience
your tenacity clearly you're someone who
believes
that failures are stepping stones to
hunch i could tell succe vibe is there
it's strong it's already growing
you found your niche but you found it
after
six channels hundreds of videos
yeah give up i want everybody watching
to be encouraged by that
because again it can be so deflating and
so discouraging
when you put your time your energy into
10 videos 50 videos
100 videos you don't necessarily get
results but that entire process has been
education
it's been insight tell us how you've
stayed motivated
and when you actually decided like i'm
gonna abandon this channel or this
channel is just not working
how you got the courage to get up and
start again
um so how i stay motivated is i do pay
attention to the big channels that i
am going for if that makes sense um you
know
i i always tell myself there's however
many viewers on youtube
what was the number you put out there's
like billions of viewers yeah over two
billion monthly
active users two billion monthly users
i believe i can get a million of them
that is such a small fraction compared
to
two billion um and yeah just watching
the big channels
watching them grow something i do
regularly is i go to a big channel that
i really like
i go to their videos and i sort them
oldest to newest and i go and i watch
their
content that was not so great at first
and they watched them grow
and to me that's really inspiring and
i'm like if this average person who's
just like me can do it
then i can do it too as long as i stay
dedicated and focused
that's what i'm going for as long as i
stay dedicated and focused casey
casey katie you got me fired up pluto
has got me fired up and uh i'm so
grateful that you were
able to come on coffee with candle today
let's stay connected i'm excited i'll
check in with you in like six months
a year when you're at 50 000 subscribers
100 000
um because uh you got it you got your
niche market
you know what to do you got your plan
let's build
thank you i really appreciate it alright
take care
bye my friends
commitment is the foundation of all
great accomplishments i get it man we
get punched in the face
we get setbacks we get whole channels
we've started
i have often said i've got four failed
youtube channels on my way to two
successful ones
katie has had five to six channels
hundreds of videos
but instantly i could tell when i
watched her videos okay she already gets
editing she's getting the hook she's got
the end cards
skill by skill she's been building it up
and she found her niche
sometimes it takes you time to find your
niche market sometimes you experiment in
different
types of channels and if you're willing
to pivot and willing to keep learning
to keep learning and willing to keep
growing
and willing to not give up uh big things
are possible and so
hit the like button if you've been
getting value out of this let me know
what you
i've been sipping on during this coffee
with kennel i've got to go get some more
coffee
somebody were wondering where do you get
the ryzen grind think media mug
thinkmediamerch.com and i'll drop
a link to that in the
link section if you want to check out
some of the merch
look we had a great session today and
thank you for everybody who came on i
appreciate seeing everybody
in the back of the um back of the studio
here in stream yard but i'm 10 minutes
away from my
next obligation i'm excited because i'm
going to try to do another one of these
soon for those that have been a part of
the youtube
influence challenge this happens weekly
so if you would love to jump on a coffee
with kennel it's going to be
happening in the group it's going to be
happening on my sean kennel page and
then on think marketing
and so every week we do this and so
absolutely would love to have you on the
show
in the future as a reminder there is a
training coming up tonight
where i'm going to have an extended time
of q a as well
uh i definitely am going to rest a
little bit today i've got a couple
meetings and some coaching calls coming
up and i'm going to drink more coffee uh
but i'm gonna be fired up for tonight
and um definitely for those in the
challenge
know that the replays are up for just a
few more hours they come down tonight
and then um hit the like button if you
got value out of the session
today um so many great we had stephen on
evan on
um and uh katie um
and i missed her name from columbia
south america
as well and so uh just a great session
today
thank you for being here um and i
encourage you to check out a couple
resources
man our mentality is so critical and so
there is that new video over on video
influencers if you want to watch that
just click or tap the screen
or just head over to the channel and
it's all about 17 content hacks so you
can create your best hacks during
quarantine
really it's going to help you stay
motivated lead during this time
not shrink back but press in punch fear
in the face punch perfectionism in the
face
and press record appreciate you so much
thanks for being a part of this
video today and i will see you in the
next coffee with kennel